hello nfv and welcome to party global
2021 my name is zachary i'm very happy
to be here and be your host for this
session and i would like to
welcome gabi
to talk a topic about the data science
in enterprising holistic approach and
gaby is a
really good ending statistic and is fun
loving programming
and
his passioning on data science and after
completing the master of science in
business analysis degree um she joined
the brilliant creative and human and fun
ai and automatic automation team at cgi
inside of
um technology practice
so let's move the time to gaby to share
her session thank you gaby thank you
zack let me get things going here
so
as he mentioned i'll be talking around
data science in the enterprise where
i'll be tackling data science from a
holistic approach today
so like you mentioned i'm a senior data
scientist at cgi on the ai and
automation team i help our clients not
only implement data-driven solutions but
i act as a thought leader i help advise
on strategy and growth opportunities for
analytics inside the organization
i've seen a lot of successful and some
not so successful data science projects
so today what i really wanted to do was
just share some of my best practices
that i've learned to ensure that your
next data science project is set up for
success
so
just an agenda here i'll start with a
quick overview of the main differences
between eda and production then we'll
move into the process that we can follow
when we're developing data science um
projects that need to be
productionalized and then i'll walk you
through these best practices with
a current example that i've done at my
client that's an oil and gas client
where we've been doing some anomaly
detection on their iot data coming from
compressors
so i'm sure many of you have seen this
statistic before or something pretty
similar but the reality is that only
about 20 of analytic insights will
actually deliver business outcomes and
the reason for this is because so many
projects get stuck in that exploratory
phase and
the analysis or models are not deployed
across the organization to actually
start delivering that business value and
we spend so much time exploring that
data and proving a model could be
beneficial here but how do we actually
take it across to that finish line and
ensure that you know it's not only being
implemented but it's actually being used
day to day in the end users decision
making
and the answer to that is to really
focus on your people and your processes
that you have in place so
whenever we think about a transformation
we think in terms of people process and
technology
today you know almost every organization
is going through a digital
transformation and ai is kind of the
heart of that transformation so when we
think about ai and what's needed from a
people process and technology standpoint
what we see is that companies are
actually rarely lacking data tools or
things that fit inside of that
technology bucket
there's a plethora of data out there and
many open source tools available to
start analyzing your data
what most organizations are lacking
though is centered around a people and
process domain so
correctly structuring your analytics
team within your organization to drive
out those projects is a huge step that
needs to be taken by an analytics leader
to make sure that you're enabling a
data-driven culture and you're helping
your company realize you know the full
potential of analytical capabilities
what's even more interesting is you know
not only does setting up this team allow
data science to grow and flourish but it
actually helps the business understand
how to utilize data scientists to their
full potential so
as data scientists you know we have very
desirable skill sets we know how to
program we know how to visualize and
analyze data as well as build predictive
and statistical models so
you know due to this knowledge across
multiple domains we often get pinged and
pulled to put out fires resulting in
data science initiatives getting thrown
to the back burner or projects being
paused instead of working through a
deliberate project and process scoped
out by an analytics team i know i have a
lot of heartburn here this has happened
in many of my projects so this is just
why it's so
important to ensure that you have a
process that both the business and the
data scientists are educated around
so that you can push that project
forward through any obstacles that may
arise
before we dive into how to structure a
project for success by focusing on the
people and process i first want to touch
on how different the people and
processes can look from an exploratory
project to a project that must be
productionized
so let's start where we spend the most
time in an eda project a bulk of your
time is going to be spent on exploring
the data doing model development and
assessing that feasibility if you're
building a model that needs to be
productionalized there needs to be a
really heavy investment up front on
defining that use case and setting up
the correct team there's also going to
be a heavy investment at the end when
you're operationalizing those results
in terms of who's involved on an
exploratory analysis project the
business usually comes up with idea and
then hands it over to a data scientist
and data engineer who works through that
process hand in hand but if you're
building a model that's going to be
productionalized you absolutely need to
involve colleagues from the business
coupled with your data scientists and
data engineers who are working together
if not every day every week
and lastly if we look at the process and
the resulting output an exploratory
analysis project you'll likely be
developing until you have that final
model or analysis and then at that point
you know you're going to present it out
maybe using some visuals and you might
have a local model ready to show that
demo
but if you're building a model for
production that process is much more
involved in terms of reading out your
result results early and often to get
that feedback from the business this way
the output is a model that is ready to
be deployed into the business and that
value has already been predefined
so we're going to take a closer look at
what that use case process roadmap
should look like talking touching on all
those things that i just mentioned
and hopefully will give you a successful
data science project um that ends with a
model in production so there's really
two major phases to this use case
process roadmap the first like i
previously previously mentioned is that
really heavy investment up front in
defining an achievable use case so this
is made up of three parts we must first
identify our use case champions and
build a team around them they are the
leaders who are trusted and have a
really good understanding of the
problems that the business faces and how
data can help solve those problems
secondly we need to educate the business
around what data science can do versus
what it can't do and conduct early
feasibility assessments
once you have done both these things it
becomes really easy to use that team to
then discover possible use cases and
prioritize them based on business value
and technical feasibility
again by focusing on this up front
you're really setting yourself up for
success versus getting through that
exploratory phase and realizing hey
there isn't much value here and this use
case isn't really feasible technically
once you have set yourself up for
success you have that right team in
place you've picked a use case that has
value and is feasible then comes that
second phase which is the execution
in this stage you'll be driving out the
development in a really iterative
process coupled with the business and
once you get that okay that the model is
looking great it's providing the outputs
we want you're going to deploy those
models into production so they can be
used across the business to aid in
decision making
so we're going to take a pretty deep
dive into each of these steps
starting with the structure of the team
so aside from creating a blended team
that involves you know not only
technical resources but those key
players in the business that most
important piece of the team is going to
be that use case champion this is a
person that's going to drive out the
project from the business side you know
they understand the value that data can
bring to solving business problems
um and they're going to advocate for
that project and be tied to its success
they'll also come to the table with some
kpis in mind you know how we can measure
the model's outputs and ensure that
there's value
but really
above all else what this person needs is
to be trusted across the business
because when it comes to deploy these
models and you need to shift those end
users into an analytical mindset you
need to start using the output of these
models
if that use case champion is behind the
project then you're going to get all
your end users behind them as well
of course there's other key roles on the
team that must exist
you know you need to have your data
engineers and your data scientists who
can actually drive out the technical
implementation
but you also need to make sure you have
smes and end users on your team so when
you're creating a use case you need to
have the end user in mind the entire way
they're the only ones who can tell you
if your modeling outputs are being
understood and at times we forget right
that these end users of our models are
not always technical so we need to make
sure that they can take action and they
understand how to interpret those
results
also many times as data scientists and
data engineers we're not experts in the
problem at hand we're experts at
building models and analyzing data so we
really need a sme or a business analyst
who has worked with the data before or
even been on the ground and encountered
you know that exact problem that we're
trying to solve for many times so that
we can fully understand what we're
trying to solve for
having this input from sneeze can really
speed up your efforts because they're
able to give you that immediate feedback
and answers to any questions you may
have
and of course in order to keep this
project on track we're going to want to
have a project manager they can be from
the business or the i.t side it can be a
blended role
it doesn't matter all that matters is
you have someone there that's
prioritizing this project and blocking
and tackling any obstacles or
distractions that may arise
now this is just a broad template of the
roles that should be present sometimes a
data scientist and data engineer they
might end up being the same person who
straddles two roles other times you know
a sme may be the same person as your end
user and vice versa and in some projects
you might have two end users helping you
and another one you might have one just
what's important is that you have at
least someone representing each of these
roles at a minimum
so now that we have you know our team
roles outlined we understand who could
be a part of our team let's talk about
educating those potential team members
so they understand what is and is not
possible with data science and
with the current tools and technologies
that we have available
a lot of times this step gets forgotten
and what ends up happening is kind of a
fundamental misunderstanding between the
business and the technical team
especially when the technical team has
to come back and tell them you know oh
this isn't going to be possible or our
model ended up having a poor accuracy
we're not going to move forward
it's also better to assess that
technical feasibility early so when
we're prioritizing those use cases we
know what's going to be easy and what's
going to be a mountain to climb over in
terms of that technical feasibility and
it also helps the business come to the
table
with use cases that can be solved for in
our current state
so for understanding data science we
usually like to host an introductory
workshop to those who will be working
with the analytics team we invite people
from all around the business and what we
really focus on is demystifying data
science so we talk about what it is we
give real world examples to help them
understand we go through our methodology
which you guys will see here in a second
and we even educate them on some basic
models such as linear regression
decision trees and the difference
between supervised and unsupervised
learning
for those on the i.t side who may have
you know familiarity with data science
um but not really understanding what
tools need to be used we host a separate
workshop building off the first one
where we go over how to use python for
data science at a very high level so
they at least become familiar with the
effort and the tools it will take to
solve the problems and along the way
you're helping those around you upskill
so that later on when these models are
deployed in the greater architecture
they can help maintain them so we start
out with you know an introduction to
jupiter notebooks open source libraries
python and a focus on pandas and
transforming and storing data
once the business and it is familiar
with what data science is and the tools
needed to solve it
we have another workshop where we
discuss the technical feasibility of
building production-facing models so we
ask a lot of probing questions like what
are the possible data sources that we
have available to work with is there
data currently that we don't have
available to us that we would like for
these use cases that means we're going
to have to build a new data pipeline
how often are all these data resources
getting refreshed if we come to the
table with a use case where we want a
model running daily but we only get that
data refreshed weekly that's not going
to work right we want to make sure that
we figure that out up front before we
get too far into it
another really important question we ask
is has the accuracy of the data been
validated do we trust it off the bat are
we going to have to spend some time
doing analysis and possibly a big effort
to clean it up
and lastly we need to be thinking about
what tools we currently have available
to us for modeling and transformation of
data um if we don't have tools available
how are we going to invest in a new one
and do we have the skill sets needed on
our team do we have data scientists data
engineers do they specialize in specific
areas
all these things are going to help us
scope out our use case figure out if we
need to invest in new resources or tools
and help in setting up our project plan
and timelines
so we have our team outlined and
educated now comes this fun part right
let's figure out what use cases we have
and which ones we can start working on
so your analytics team may already have
some use cases you know brought to the
table or you might have to conduct a
workshop for that but regardless once
you get some use cases you need to
evaluate them on two aspects so that
technical feasibility we've been talking
about and then the business value
we just got all that information about
what data we had available the skills
and the resources so per use case
knowing what we know in that area what
we need to do is rank it from 1 being
you know this is not possible in our
current state to 5 b we could do this
tomorrow if we wanted then you'll do the
same thing with business value with one
being this brings little to no value to
the business or five this is extremely
valuable with big potential cost and
time savings
so it might be apparent that those in
that top right corner are the use cases
we're going to want to drive out first
to give us a really quick win to enable
data science across an organization it's
much better to start with something
small that drives business value than to
aim really high and fail
then you'll be giving this perception
across the organization you know that
data science projects are risky they
take a long time to complete and they
might not even be successful by aiming
for these more attainable use cases
you're showing success to get the ball
rolling and all the while you know while
you're working on these um you're
actually investing in resources getting
new tools and technology so that down
the line you can tackle those bigger
ones highlighted in red it's also really
important to note that this isn't a
static process either you don't just do
this once and forget about it
you're always going to want to be
reprioritizing especially as new use
cases come down the line or you invest
in those new tools and technologies and
especially what your current business
climate is so this is an ever-changing
cycle that you need to iterate upon
often with your business in it
so let's say we picked one of those use
cases in our top right corner to start
on we already know what roles we need on
our team we know the feasibility and the
business value so it's time to really
dive in and get that development kicked
off you should spend no more than a week
getting that team together setting the
expectation picking the kpis and
officially launching that project
following that official launch
now that you know your team members and
everyone is acquainted with the
expectations it's time to revisit that
use case that was proposed and have a
couple of discovery sessions focused
around exploring the data and figuring
out what types of models you're going to
throw at this problem the technical
resources should also be relying heavily
on the business in the space to help
them understand what the actual business
need is in detail now that they have
those smes and end users at their
disposal
once you feel comfortable with you know
the data that you've analyzed and your
approach that you're going to take it's
time to begin that iterative cycle of
prepping the data modeling and
validating and then synthesizing those
results we like to keep these iterations
at two weeks maximum so that we're not
spinning our wheels on something for too
long before the business tells us you
know it's not what they were looking for
this step is really important in the
process because this is where you're
going to be getting feedback that feeds
what that next iteration should be
we like to live by the phrase you know
present early and present often so that
nothing shocking is going to come out of
this readout
and even through the process you should
be having daily standups with your team
members
asking them questions to help you
through unblockers so nothing surprising
should come out of this
once you have done enough iterations to
where the business and yourself are
happy with that final model and output
it's time to engage those stakeholders
so maybe some executive leaders
department managers and others to read
out your final results and
recommendations this is a really
important step in the process because
this is where you get that buy-in from
across the organization so it's really
time to prove that value of your work
and if things go as planned and everyone
is happy with the project outcome and
results that final step in the process
is to deploy that model across the
organization
so we've gone to this point thanks to
all our due diligence upfront by
focusing on our team and our process now
it's time to deliver that final result
so as we know there's really no value
you know in a machine learning model
unless it's deployed into production so
a business can start using it to make
decisions but what i want to caution
everyone against is that there's really
no need to boil the ocean coming out of
the gate right so start small pick a
single department or area to pilot the
model on this will give you time to
prove its value with the business by
tracking its success so using the kpis
decided upon earlier in the process
measure against these once your model
has been deployed and make sure if
possible you create a feedback loop so
that your end users can tell you um if
your predictions were correct or not
after analyzing the results for a
meaningful period of time to actually
recognize those improvements then you
can expand to other departments or the
entire organization with the evidence
knowing that this is helping the
business this would also be a really
good time to engage change management
with a bigger audience who may or may
not have used modeling outputs before
and even if they have right every output
is different the way they interpret it
and act on it is different um this
should not be left up for the discussion
right they need to know exactly how to
use it the biggest end goal here is that
your users trust your model so that data
science initiatives can continue to
thrive in the business so you want to do
everything in your power to make sure
your model and outputs are trusted
so now that you know the best practices
let's put those to the test and see how
i use them one of my most recent
projects for a client in the oil and gas
sector
so this client had to find a really bold
vision for their organization in which
they wanted to leverage near real-time
unit monitoring advanced analytics and
integrating all this into their mobile
tools to change the way their
organization is run
in phase one my team and i spent a
really good chunk of time standing up
their analytics strategy and environment
as well as driving out some proof of
concepts we set up their big data
platform using azure and data bricks as
the heart of that solution we built data
pipelines pulling in iot sensor data as
well as data from across other parts of
the organization so that we had it in
one centralized area and we engaged in
three proof of concepts or exploratory
analysis projects in tandem to showcase
the art of the possible what we could do
once we had this whole environment set
up
and then we are currently in phase two
where we have started building those
productionalized models so right now i'm
going to walk you through our valve
failure anomaly detection project where
we were successfully able to build and
deploy a model together with the
business using all those strategies we
just touched on so the first step in the
process creating that all-star team
fortunately for us like i mentioned
earlier this organization had a really
bold vision and they knew that we were
going to need a lot of resources on the
analytics side to make this come to life
so we were given two work stream leads
one from the analytics side one from
telematics that really led the business
and acted as those use case champions
for all of our use cases they're able to
hold those smes accountable and the end
users accountable for being engaged in
the project and driving that value
for end users we had field service
technicians business unit vps and
service area managers at our disposal
who we could use in our projects to
guide us when creating the model and
outputs because they would essentially
right be the ones using them at the end
of the day
and some of them also served as our
smees because many of them had come from
a hands-on background working with that
equipment and had a deep understanding
of how compressors should operate and we
also added in a few engineers to give us
a rounded perspective
i was the data scientist and data
engineer for these use cases supported
by a business facing project manager
that would keep our projects on track
and focused
we quickly realized that a lot of these
end users and smes although they knew a
lot about compressors they did not know
a lot about data science and so it was a
new concept for them and
we held training sessions where i went
over basic concepts in data science but
i tied them directly to use cases within
the oil and gas space to give them a
clear understanding
in that same session we also covered the
type of data that we currently had
available for the use cases so that the
team could come prepared to that
discovery and prioritization workshop
with some ideas in mind
here it was really important to arm our
business with as much information and
understanding as possible so that it
wasn't a wasted effort and actual
meaningful conversations and ideas were
had in that workshop
and so
moving into that workshop it ran for
about three to four hours it was very
successful we had people from all across
the business along with people from it
involved to help actually get this
conversation started we came prepared
with some historical data analysis about
common parts usage which were kind of
the most expensive when they were
repairing those machines hoping it would
trigger some thoughts and ideas which it
did
and coming out of that meeting anyone
who had suggested a use case was tasked
with filling out this use case template
form
the form include an area to talk about
the problem the potential value assess
that technical feasibility and think
through how we could incorporate a
feedback loop of course we helped them
fill this out
but at the end of this we were able to
come out of this with about 10 to 15 use
cases that needed to be prioritized on
the basis of business value and
technical feasibility
and all those ones that made it in the
top right corner we started working on
them or either have them in our pipeline
right
and so one of the ones that made it in
that top right corner was
the valve failure anomaly detection and
so here we have to analyze discharge
temperatures if we find anomalies here
they could be indicative of a bowel
failure issue and if caught in time that
could lead to big savings in time and
money for them
and so
since we did not have label data as to
what was an anomaly or not we had to use
outlier detection methods and rely
heavily on sneeze to help us understand
you know what anomalous data looked like
for discharge temperatures we receive
data every 15 minutes per tag on each
compressor there's about 2 500 units in
the fleet and we needed at least 30 days
of data for each unit to understand the
stable operating conditions
as usual you can imagine with this much
data how often we're getting it and just
kind of you know how it works with iot
data on sensors the data cleansing took
a lot of time here for us so going
through that iterative process we
realized that there were a lot of
anomalies coming from when a unit was
going down or when it was coming back up
that weren't actual true anomalies or
even when the unit was shut down right
we were getting readings that we
shouldn't have so we had a lot rely
really heavily on our smee expertise
here when we would read out our demos
and show them what our models were
outputting as actual anomalies
and get their input as to if they would
have thought the same thing
so in total it took about six weeks of
going through that cyclical process so
three full iterations and then we had
the model running internally with our
group for just a small subset of units
and producing outputs for two weeks that
the smes were checking and analyzing to
ensure that they were true anomalies so
once they had confidence in our model in
the go-ahead
we moved into piloting and deploying
that model for a couple of service areas
so our model is currently in the pilot
stage it has been for about one month it
runs two times a day in our data bricks
environment with a really lightweight
deployment outputting our predictions
into an excel sheet that is then you
know automated and sent out to each
service area manager to review and then
dispatch their field service technicians
to check on that unit
we are tracking which anomalies are two
anomalies meaning we saw a resulting
valve issue which will help us measure
against our kpis we have set which
include reducing unscheduled downtime
events you know that in turn saves the
organization money by speeding up the
call to action and saving the unit from
a potential bigger wreck
things are going well so we are
currently planning for our next rollout
phase to other service areas but before
doing so we want to have a bit more of a
sophisticated end-to-end deployment
using power bi as our dashboarding tool
to serve up those predictions versus
just getting an email um in excel
and so we have decided to engage our
change management team in the process so
that they can train these new end users
how to use the dashboards and
predictions and what actions should be
taken off of them
so that was just one of many use cases
that we've been able to productionalize
on this project thanks to the great team
i'm surrounded by and those leaders who
understand the importance of building up
a strong business team who's educated
around data science i really appreciate
y'all's time i hope i was able to drive
home the importance of focusing on the
people and process surrounding your data
science projects
feel free to use this time to ask any
questions and if not i have my email up
my linkedin up here you can also contact
me through the slack channel if you want
to take this conversation further but i
look forward to connecting with you and
i hope you guys have a great rest of
your conference
thank you gaby
and then one question from the um q a
session
is was the model predicting value failed
in advance to the failed
um predict maintenance or after the fact
of fail
it was um predicting it before it would
happen so that was the whole idea of
having it run two times a day when they
come in in the morning they wanted to
see that anomaly and be able to act on
that anomaly before the unit actually
went down and then when it was running
in the afternoon
it was taking that data points from the
morning and again seeing if we could act
on that before the end of the day and
people had to go home and the unit would
eventually shut down from the discharge
temperature being out of whack
okay
so another question is about can you
give us an idea of what your team for
this project looked like how many member
yeah absolutely so like i mentioned i
was the only data scientist and the data
engineer straddling both those roles um
in terms of a use case champion we had
those two available to us so the
analytics work stream lead and the
telematics were extremely were a part of
all of our stand-ups and calls leading
that team we actually have a pretty big
team of smes and end users so on all of
our calls i would say we have about five
to six on there with three being actual
people who are hands on the ground and
the other ones being people who had done
that previously and who are now more on
the managerial side of things
okay thank you and one more question
from the trap boss is do you have any
experience of of people not being on
board with the new ml system being
implemented implemented or not fully
understanding why they need to change
from old weight to a new way
yeah absolutely so this is really why we
like to engage that change management
process and why it's so important to
prove the value and have that use case
champion there's always going to be some
pushback we've experienced that a lot
right these people are really
experiencing what they do so sometimes i
think they don't need our model's help
but what we've seen is by actually
showing how our model works and showing
that we can save them time we've been
able to get them on board and then
having those use case champions behind
us really rallying the team together
and telling them that you know they
should be using this model it is helpful
um we've been able to kind of bypass
that a little bit but of course that's
that's always going to exist
okay thank you so much gabi so our time
is over so if they have more discussion
we can move to the snack or get it hand
and thank you ab to talk and for being
part of the pi data global 2021 thank
you so much
awesome thank you
you